Democratic Virginia Governor Terry
McAuliffe is with us now from Richmond
for his first national television
interview since last weekend's events in
Charlotte so good morning governor
good morning Charlie it's good to be
with you should all Confederate
memorials and monuments be taken down I
think so I issued a statement to that
effect yesterday this is my first
interview after what happened on
Saturday here in Charlottesville
I thought important that I speak to the
citizens of the Commonwealth so I've
spent the last five days traveling all
over Virginia talking about healing
reconciliation how we move forward
together but I did issue a statement
last night that's why one reason I want
to talk to Charlie is they need to come
down there divisive symbols several
years ago I used executive authority to
take the Confederate flag off of our
license plates here in Virginia I don't
have the authority to do that with
monuments local control local
jurisdictions as well as the General
Assembly would control but I did say
yesterday as my lieutenant governor
Ralph Northam did it's time for these
monuments to come down it's time for us
to move together after what happened in
Charlottesville but let me just say this
Charlie's that just about monuments this
was a big issue that happened in this
country on Saturday these people who
came to Charlottesville the neo-nazis
the alt-right
they weren't here about a statue they
went to the University of Virginia on
Friday night with their torches that had
nothing to do with the statue there is
hatred there was bigotry that has been
unleashed in this country and we need to
understand how what's happened most
importantly what we can do going forward
as a nation and does the president's
response to this suggest that he's unfit
to be President
well I could say this I disagree
strongly with the president in his
remarks that this was all about the LEAs
statue as I just mentioned it was it I
have lost three great citizens yesterday
Heather hires funeral tomorrow we will
have to put to rest
trooper Burke Bates who had been part of
my executive protection detail and then
on Saturday lieutenant Jay Cullen who'd
been my pilot this breaks her heart you
have DeAndre Harris who was viciously
beaten by four or five individuals as I
said on Saturday let me be clear
hatred we got to address it these were
not Patriots these were cowards over my
shoulder as Barbara John's with 16 years
old led the revolt at Prince Edward
County Virginia when we had white
schools and black schools and she said
our schools are inferior and she led a
revolt a 400 student in the 50s that is
what we need is leader those are
patriots the men and women in uniform in
the president and I've talked to the
president let us use this time to bring
people together we are a United States
of America and the hatred that I saw on
Saturday
I'm telling Charlie I've never seen the
language and the things were said about
individuals members the african-american
community members with Jewish faith
members of the LGBT community there's no
place for it in Virginia I told him to
go home but let's be honest there's no
place in America for this type of hatred
so I've established a reconciliation
committee we're moving forward and to
see those people at University of
Virginia on the lawn yesterday that is
who Virginia is governor did you say
that you spoke with President Trump and
what did you tell him well when I talked
to him you know he called me right
before he gave his press conference I
said mr. president and I've been seeing
the the video all day this it's it's
hatred it's bigotry it's racism it needs
to stop in this country and I said
listen let us work together for
reconciliation let us go forward to
bring our nation back together again and
you know he agreed with me on the phone
call but but then governor after that
phone call he had that remarkable news
conference and when it was over you
issued a statement saying we need real
leadership in this country my state in
this country is still reeling from all
the hatred what does real leadership
look like to you in this case and do you
still want him to come back to
Charlottesville
that was not leadership what I saw and
as I went out and did it myself
represented not only Virginia but I
thought where America was those remarks
are dividing people we cannot be
dividing people people came and
protested the other day here in
Charlottesville one group came they came
heavily armed you saw the pictures of
individuals walking around with semi
autumn
rifles through our streets we knew the
FBI and the DHS has helped us with
intelligence we knew these folks were
coming armed and they wanted to harm
people on the other side were the folks
who were protesting hatred and bias and
bigotry they are two separate entirely
groups one was for uniting our country
the other side was to harm people do you
want him to come you would asked him to
come over the weekend do you still feel
that way listen if the president wants
to come to Charlottesville and address
our citizens talk about how we can heal
as a nation and how we meet need to move
before that is what the President of the
United States should do I do not want
the President to come here to continue
on with the speeches that he's given the
last couple days those speeches are
dividing us people now feel comfortable
nor that they can come into a city you
know they used to wear hoods now they
wear hoods and spew their hatred and
bigotry and bias there is no place for
that in this country and anyone who
incites that or encourages it allows
this type of behavior let me be clear
you have no place here in Virginia we do
not want you and I'll be honest with you
we don't want you here in America this
hate speech has got to end let us
continue to work together let's build a
great United States of America that's
who we are
governor McAuliffe thank you for joining
us for your first interview we
appreciate it